what do you think about
uh like tesla's dojo efforts
or it can be bigger than tesla in
general it's kind of like the tense
torrent
uh trying to innovate like this is the
dichotomy like
should a company try to from scratch
build its own
neural network training hardware well
personally i think it's great
so we need lots of experiments right and
there's lots of
startups working on this and they're
pursuing different things
you know i was there when we started
dojo and it was sort of like
what's the unconstrained computer
solution
to go do very large training problems
and then there's fun stuff like you know
we said well we have this 10 000 watt
board to cool
well you go talk to guys at spacex and
they think 10 000 watts is a really
small number not a big number
yeah and and there's brilliant people
working on it i'm
curious to see how it'll come out i i
couldn't tell you you know
i know it pivoted a few times since i
left so so the
cooling does seem to be a big problem i
do like what
elon said about it which is like we
don't want to do the thing
unless it's way better than the
alternative whatever the alternative is
so it has to be way better than like
racks of gpus yeah and the other thing
is just like
you know you know the tesla autonomous
driving hardware
it was only serving one software stack
and the hardware team and the software
team are tightly coupled
you know if you're building a general
purpose ai solution then you know
there's so many different customers with
so many different needs
now something andre said is i think this
is amazing
ten years ago like vision recommendation
uh language were completely different
disciplines
we said the people literally couldn't
talk to each other and three years ago
it was all neural networks but the very
different neural networks and recently
it's converging on one set of networks
they vary a lot in size obviously they
vary in data varying outputs
but the technology has converged a good
bit yeah these
transformers behind gbt3 it seems like
they could be applied to video they
could be applied to a lot of
yeah and it's like and they're all
really so it's like to literally replace
letters with pixels yeah it does vision
it's amazing so and then size actually
improves the thing
so the bigger it gets the more compute
you throw at it the better it gets
the more data you have the better it
gets so
so so then you start to wonder well is
that a fundamental thing or is
is this just another step to some
fundamental understanding about this
kind of computation
you